- [Tanya] All women in the
United States are impacted
but black women are the most vulnerable
and therefore dying at higher levels.
(Introduction Music)
December of 2019,
Shawnee Benton Gibson,
Shamony's mother put
out essentially a call
to action on Instagram
inviting people to a
celebration of Shamony's life.
Paula saw that on Instagram
and said, "Hey, I think
we should reach out and,
and try to film, film them."
Shawnee actually picked up the phone.
She talked with Paula, Paula told her
about what we were trying to do.
And she invited us in to film Aftershock.
Which was the life celebration.
Amber Rose Isaac passed
away in April of 2020,
and Omari,
when he heard about
Amber's passing reached out
to Bruce McIntyre. He was there
as a support system for him
told him we were working on the film.
Asked Bruce if he would be open to us,
talking to him and we did.
And, and that's how we
ended up with everybody.
(Instrumental Music)
- [Paula] The way we started was really
following our protagonists,
following the stories
of Shamony and Amber,
and their families, right?
Shawnee, Omari, and Bruce.
Through their stories,
we kind of compliment their
stories with information.
So that provided the backbone
and the information
came secondary to that.
We had a shared vision.
We didn't want this to
be a talking heads film,
a survey film.
This is a character driven film.
And the way we wanted to educate for lack
of a better word,
was really through the lived experiences
of our protagonists. The
human to human connection.
Really going into Shamony
and Amber's stories.
That's the best part of
filmmaking is storytelling.
And that's how you get
people to pay attention.
And then you slip in the statistics.
- [Tanya] If you really deal
with the most vulnerable,
you deal with everyone, talking about the
maternal health crisis
in the United States.
I mean, all women in the
United States are impacted
by the fact that we don't
have midwifery integrated
into women's healthcare, right?
But black women are the most
vulnerable and therefore
dying at higher levels.
So you tell the story of what's
happening with black women
and certainly the racism
has an impact as well.
But then you also get at the
overall healthcare system
in general, that where
everybody is impacted by.
We really had a shared vision
about, and that was one
of the wonderful things
about our collaboration
from the first time that we
sat down and started talking.
I think we both understood how
we wanted to tell this story
and we did not want it to
be a doom and gloom story.
We wanted to show that there are solutions
to the problem dignified and
safe birthing should be first
and foremost, I think for,
for me and for Paula, you know
we, we are hoping that
there's a cultural shift
in how we think about birth, right?
I think often the first
thing that comes to
people's minds first, it's like,
oh, I'm so excited for you.
Oh, that's gonna be really painful.
You know?
So instead of having the
conversation about the pain
of birthing all the time,
or are the negative sides.
That we really want people
to come away, feeling hopeful
excited, inspired, you know,
moved by the film to action.
- [Paula] Through the, the filming of
of Felicia's birth specifically
and her birth journey.
We wanted to reclaim what
birth looks like in film.
Usually doesn't look like that.
It's, it's a, woman's
screaming and ranting and she's
in a hospital and it's like
this like horrible thing.
And we really took our time
to show a real process.
It's a long scene.
And, and we did that purposely.
So we wanted to really
show what it could be like
she's the hope and what
every woman deserves.
(Music)
You know, we want birthing
people, families, women, to, to
to know that they have choices
around birthing options.
They can choose what kind of
healthcare provider they want.
Maybe they want a midwife.
You know?
Maybe they want an OB there's
different birth settings that
that they can choose from.
So people don't realize that
there's other ways to do this.
Every other industrialized
country has choice.
And their rates are far better than ours.
And we have these horrible rates
because they force everyone into a system.
As Neel, Dr. Shah
says in our film, "OB's
are trained surgeons.
Labor and delivery floors
are set up like ICUs,"
you know 99% of pregnant people.
You put them there.
You're gonna see a lot of surgery.
Pregnancy is not a one size fits all.
So we hope to show choice.
I really hope there's accountability
within the medical system.
Hospitals, administrators
insurance companies, providers, you know
they need to provide human-centered care.
I was pregnant myself
through making this film
the first part of it, and then postpartum
then it was a pandemic.
My daughter was born in March, 2020.
That time period was, was especially hard.
I did speak to someone, you know
a doula therapist once
a week to decompress
and really try to, you know
I tried to separate the work
from, from the personal life.
But as Tanya said, it was a,
a heavy time in the world.
We're covering heavy subject matter.
And I really just took
strength from the team
making the film with us
from the protagonist, from
Omari, Shawnee and Bruce.
And when I, you know
shifted that mindset of
like despair, you know
and shifted it towards, you
know, this film like action and
and the impact the film can
make, then, then it like
you know, charged me up to,
to focus on that part of this.
- [Tanya] You know, I hope
people come away understanding
that the U.S maternal mortality crisis,
how it's affecting black women is all part
of the overall reproductive
justice conversation.
You know, there really is an attack
on women and it's not
just abortion rights.
It's also birthing rights and
birthing choices and options.
So I hope people understand
that this is all part
of one conversation. And we
have to care about our women.
And that's how we care about our families.
And that's how we care
about our communities.
(Outro Music)